can't think yourself into writing but
you can write yourself into thinking so
just start
just for you know the person who's
listening or watching who has a creative
impulse and they feel like they have
something to say or there's something
deep in them that feels like they want
to express an emotion a thought a story
how do you speak to that person who is
trying to you know bring forth some
expression into the world
I mean I I struggle with it too I mean I
think
the best advice is
you know writers write you just gotta
write you'll be willing to throw it out
you have to be willing to do it just for
yourself
and everybody is interesting it took me
a long time to think anything about me
was interesting I always wrote for for
people like Jim Carrey who seems
fascinating and I always thought God I'm
so boring what about this life is
interesting and then when I finally
realize maybe what I'm going through is
interesting my career completely took
off the moment I just accepted that like
the 40 year old version it's just an
expression of my own anxieties and
people really connected with it so you
have to have some confidence that your
story is interesting
you know someone said you know the
greatest gift you can give people is
your story and that was a big thing for
me because I really thought who the hell
wants my story and so you have to be
willing to be vulnerable and put
yourself out there I mean there's a lot
of work that you have to do but you have
to do the same thing that I do every day
which is can I just
Let It Go just see what comes out of me
and you know there's simple things that
are really helpful you know one is a
from uh what is her name
she has that book Bird by bird oh and
lemon and she has she had the line to
one of her books where she said it's a
down up Theory you got to get it down
then fix it up George Saunders said a
version of that which is
you know I can write a really mediocre
short story
but give me five years to punch it up
and it'll be great you know you have to
just like see what comes out
and trust that and then you you switch
gears like for me creativity is always
there's one mode which is spewing and
then one mode which is assessing and
editing and you can't do it at the same
time and I think a lot of people the
reason why they're not creative is they
try to do it at the same time they're
judging every sentence as it's coming
out and you have to just kind of blow it
all out and then the next day look at it
and go what's a value here and I feel
like that's maybe the most important
lesson that I've learned even the
precursor to that the thought
um that I don't have anything worth
saying or my life isn't interesting
enough like overcoming that hurdle to
even get to the point where you're
sitting down ready to write anything
down and
understanding that your experience has
value you know the specific is the
universal like the more specific you are
about it
um the more opportunity there is to
connect with something universally human
about all of us and you know you growing
up in Suburban you know Long Island and
having the experiences that you had and
the fact that you you know kind of had
to go to war with yourself over the
value of your own experience is I think
interesting and and instructional and
and inspirational that you had to do
that for yourself to get to that place
of like freedom
to express yeah it took a long time but
I worked with people who did it like
shanling and Paul feig on Freaks and
Geeks and on Freaks and Geeks I started
pitching some more personal stuff and I
saw that those scenes were good yeah I
wrote a lot of stuff about divorce on
the show and Bill's mom dating the gym
teacher and
Neil's Neil's obsession with
ventriloquism as a way to deal with his
parents divorce you know and I saw oh
that stuff seems to be working and it's
small I mean even like if you think of
like the moment you first tried to kiss
a girl
is there anything more dramatic than
that but we all have that moment right
and all these moments are can be
fascinating I mean I think a lot of my
best work is just someone's pregnant
what do we do I mean they're not it's
not Ghostbusters right it's it's uh just
the simplest thing in in recovery
there's a saying like the facts of
someone else's experiences may be
different but the kind of emotional
landscape the emotions are what you know
you can connect with when people share
their stories Etc and even if you think
and you were talking about this with
respect to a 40 year old virgin like
it's really a story about like
shame and guilt you know which is
something most people can connect with
in various ways and it's it's draped on
this very heightened story about this
extreme character but part of the reason
why I think it's a big hit is because
beneath the surface it's grappling with
something that everybody can relate to
yeah it's about am I lovable am I a
freak
and how that can get enlarged and shut
down your whole life so when we started
writing that Steve curl and I we said
let's just write it real like what what
would this feel like how would it have
happened if you tried to face it and you
didn't know how what disasters would
happen along the way but that is why
people connect to it because Steve does
such a good job
being really honest about how scared he
is to be found out and that there's no
way at the end of the day you would want
to be with him and I think everybody on
some level has that voice he really knew
what I was like you would run yes and
then at the end he says
I'm a virgin I always have been
I am having I I will admit like in a
moment of vulnerability to to begin this
I'm having a little bit of an outer body
experience you're somebody who's like
been in my life you know in a parasocial
way for you know and I'm sure you have
this experience a lot
um so it's you know it's meaningful for
me to meet you and for you to be open to
doing this because 25 years ago this day
I was like broken and on my way to rehab
and thinking like my life was completely
over and so I'm very present at the
moment reflecting back on this Arc that
I've been on
um congratulations and so to be sitting
with you here today is sort of a
punctuation mark on that which is cool I
feel like it's going to be your best
podcast I think so I think something's
going to happen Vision yes
it has to be we can't have the 25th
anniversary with a really lame podcast
yeah let's not do that
um you know we lived very different
lives but I think one thing that we
share is a curiosity about other people
and in thinking about kind of your
origin story and how you started with
this Obsession and fascination with
comedy and Comedians and the kind of
gumption to reach out to you know these
people as a young person and having them
be receptive
um what is it about other comedians in
comedy that you still you still want to
like learn from these people you still
want to figure out what makes them tick
I just always had this weird instinct to
get in the room with people
I think it's because I was just such a
fan to start so the idea of meeting
anyone was a big thing for me as a
little kid oh you could meet
Robert Conrad remember Robert Conrad
from Bob the black Jeep when I was a
little kid you're on vacation and like
there he is oh my god let's chase him
let's let's find him and so I collected
autographs and my grandmother was
friends as a with this comedian Toady
Fields who was you know a Joan Rivers
like comedian and she sang and and it
always seemed like she was the coolest
person that we knew people talked about
her in in a grand way like there was
this special person in our lives Tony
fields and she you know was a you know
and not classically beautiful woman
that's what she talked about on stage
and but loved herself
self-deprecating hilarious amazing
singer
and at one point she she had diabetes
and she had to have her leg amputated
and I went to see her when I was 10.
and I always look back at it and think
it just must have had a massive impact
to see her get all of these standing
ovations and the crowd loved her so much
and I I probably felt other and weird
and the nerd and to see this woman who
was so wonderful
get that type of reaction I think it had
a big effect on like locked in on your
brain I think somewhere I just I just
saw like oh there's other paths to
success you don't have to be the
quarterback you you don't have to be the
most handsome guy in the room there's a
there's a way to connect with people and
so I always loved watching comedians on
the talk shows and was always tracking
them like they were athletes and it just
never ended after I interviewed people
in high school I met a Dave Edgar Dave
Edgars the writer and he uh has a
charity 826 which raises uh money for
literacy programs around the country and
I said well I have all these old
interviews maybe we can put them in a
book and I'll give all the money to you
and I'll do a couple of new ones and it
just sold a lot and I I noticed that it
had a big impact on young creative
people so then I said well maybe I'll do
another one of almost all new ones and
then it's just excuse for me to just say
that what I said when I was a kid how do
you do it why do you do it how do you
feel and now that I'm in the same
profession as everyone it's like how are
we doing here's here's my experiences
are you okay are you falling apart are
you insane are we evolving and so the
conversations get much richer than when
I was 15 years right right right and do
you feel like you're still learning
about comedy oh yeah that there's no end
to what you can discover
no and because there's no answers to
anything in comedy I mean you know how
they know like there are certain beats
in music that will always make you dance
there's just themes that are consistent
with comedy it's really an experiment
and you just don't know if something's
gonna work ever right no matter how much
you think you know you might make a
movie go in a movie theater you're sure
it's rocking and there are places where
it just bombs and you were completely
wrong right and there was no way to
anticipate that do you find that
exciting or frustrating after all these
years I mean there is yeah that that
sort of quality of Comedy the
elusiveness of it uh you just don't know
it's it's something you can't quite I
mean there's rules I'm sure and there's
structure and all of that is wrote for
you I'm certain but on some level the
mystery of it all you know persists and
there's something about stand up where
you can get up and practice it and you
get the feedback in real time and you
refine Etc but when you're making a TV
show or a movie
you don't you're you're operating a bit
in a vacuum yeah because you don't know
how it's ultimately going to play even
if you're laughing or I guess you just
have to trust your instinct and surround
yourself with talented people and why do
people laugh because I'm not very
intellectual about it there are people
who could really talk about laughs and
why it happens and surprise and they
understand the psychology I have no idea
I'd never talk about it in those terms
so people say what is comedy or try to
get philosophical about it yeah I know
nothing I really do know nothing other
than instincts and I know that people
are interested in the struggles of
people that we're all struggling and
watching other people struggle in ways
that we relate to uh makes us laugh and
we root for people to do better because
we're trying to do better so I
understand you know the core emotional
rules of it but why
you know Maya Rudolph in a wedding dress
going to the bathroom in the middle of
the street gets a big laugh I can't
really scientifically explain it or
anticipate it because what we usually do
is we shoot something like that and
if it doesn't work we cut it out yeah a
year later you're like didn't get a
laugh and if it didn't that's just not
in the movie you know so I always
overshoot and shoot a lot of extra
things because I don't know on top of
that there's this added layer of of
timeliness to the whole thing like it's
rare for a comedy to hold up over
decades a lot of Comedy you go back you
thought it was hilarious you can't wait
to share it with your friend and you're
like wait you know you're not laughing
anymore
um you know the for every Life of Brian
there's a you know there's a you know
just the litter you know tons of movies
out there and TV shows that you know
just don't for whatever reason hold up
in that way like what is it about comedy
that Roots itself to the moment in a way
um that you know drama seems to be able
to transcend a little bit more easily I
mean sometimes the pace of things change
your questions
I mean I think about things that
haven't held up I mean usually it's
because
I mean things don't hold up usually
because they're not authentic in some
way I feel like if you're true to your
time and true to the characters and the
story they have a better chance of
holding up if you see the apartment the
Billy Wilder movie you know with Jack
Lemmon and Shirley maclain it completely
holds up and there's a lot of movies
like that but sometimes when you're
taking big swings or doing sillier
things you maybe as time passes you go
oh that was too broad or we don't get
those references anymore but I'm pretty
sure if you watch airplane today you
would laugh yeah yeah so that that holds
up still yeah and anytime you know
something of mine airs somewhere or is
on a new streamer I love going online to
see what people make of it now so funny
people which we made in 2009 it just
went up on Netflix it was number five on
Netflix and so that's probably it could
be more people than saw it when it came
out right that's the weird thing about
the streamers I'm sure it's a love hate
relationship that you have but the
ability for those platforms to resurface
older material and suddenly put it in
front of way more eyeballs that ever saw
it in the you know on its initial run
it's it's remarkable because that's all
you want is for your things yeah to not
disappear down the algorithm in some
digital black hole This is 40 has been
on Netflix and people walk up to me more
than they did when
when it came out and that's great
because I feel like people don't watch
it as if it's old they really watch it
like it's brand new yeah content and if
you you know other than sometimes the
phones are larger right everyone's going
why does Adam Sandler have a flip phone
I mean you know I always try to dress
people in clothes that I think will not
age badly so you know Seth Rogen's in a
t-shirt yeah it could be in a t-shirt
today it doesn't make it look like it's
the 40s Freaks and Geeks is like that I
mean my kids love that you know that
that felt like it it got new life during
the pandemic maybe not to the extent of
something like you know the office or
friends but you know to have new
generations discovering stuff that you
did a long time ago has to be cool as
well yeah I mean no one watched Freaks
and Geeks when it was on that's what we
were canceled so the fact that uh you
know that was 24 years ago that people
are watching it right now and yeah I
rarely meet young people that haven't
seen it which is crazy right and lately
I've been trying to think can I let go
of my sense of time
so like I made things in many different
eras many different years can I look at
it like they all are
from the same moment like why do I have
to think of it as something 24 years old
could I think of freaks and gigs like we
did it this year so when you're when
you're making it you're conscious of
that timelessness quality yeah and I and
for myself too in my emotional
relationship to it things that are in
the distant past can I refresh it in my
own mind and go what's the difference if
I made that in 2005 or in 2023 yeah well
you must you mentioned authenticity I
mean that's certainly a you know a huge
recurring like sort of trademark or
theme and everything that you do and you
know the work that you've done that that
has stuck with me and we're like the
same age so the work that really
resonates with me is the more personal
stuff like this is 40 and funny people
and
um and I feel like you
like if I had to think of what
distinguishes you or or a Hallmark of
everything that you do it's it's sort of
taking those mundane quotidian moments
that are highly relatable telling them
telling those stories in a very specific
way that's authentic to you like that
idea of the the specific is the
universal like the more specific in a
counter-intuitive way becomes the thing
that connects with the most number of
people and telling stories that kind of
fall in the gaps between what we're used
to seeing like in between the highlights
like what's going on you know at
breakfast or whatever you know in a way
that is probably you know very specific
to your life and yet you're touching on
something that you know we can all
connect with it's funny you say that
because when we did this TV show love on
Netflix with Paul rust
and uh and Gillian Jacobs the whole idea
was to show every single step in a
relationship so if they bumped into each
other and then didn't talk for a few
weeks let's show the few weeks that show
the pauses in between if they break up
let's show what they do when they're
broken up and who else they go out with
and then before then later they come
together I mean that's always something
that I'm interested in at some point
someone said
you know these are movies where you take
the supporting actors or actresses and
make them the leads it's these are the
characters it's like if there was a
movie about Bruno Kirby and Carrie
Fisher from uh When Harry Met Sally you
would love that movie right like I want
to go home with them for a little bit
right the the Side Story over there like
that's the more interesting thing is
that a conscious thing when you're
reviewing material and trying to figure
out what you want to be involved in like
the process of deciding where you're
going to invest your time and your
energy for the next you know however
many years it takes to get something
onto a screen I think I just relate to
those people and so I'm always in that
space because I don't you know relate to
the super handsome hero I like that kind
of movie but I I relate to the goofy
person next to them who's too tired to
keep up as they're going up the mountain
yeah yeah that's you know I'm a John
Candy guy yeah and so and I always feel
you know a little bit insecure in spaces
and so most the comedy comes from
you know whatever my anxieties things
I'm trying to get over things I'm trying
to learn about or deal with and so it
inherently isn't heroic it's just how do
you survive high school how do you
survive having a baby how do you make
your marriage work you know the simple
things to me you have so much drama in
them because
that that is the the most rewarding
stuff but also the most challenging
stuff and the weirdo making Heroes out
of the weirdos or the people that are in
between like in the cracks yeah I mean I
I remember we were promoting Knocked Up
and Seth was always really funny about
the fact that the poster was just his
face and it said what would you do if
this guy got you pregnant and said he
said like so like that's enough to sell
the movie like just my face is enough
you know and uh and he was like it
doesn't make any sense because everyone
is like me he's like the world is like
me no one's like Brad Pitt they're like
me I'm not the exception and uh and I
think that's true that we all you know
feel like that yeah you know how many
people feel strong and fantastic yeah
they're accomplishing their goals and
feel mentally strong we all feel like a
mess so it's fun to write about people
who are a mess yeah
um that that's the same thing with with
the show girls like I was reading that
HP what's that HBO book oh the kind of
like the history box yeah yeah Tinderbox
and there's a whole section on there on
on how girls came to be and at one point
uh Lena shares her like two-page brief
or whatever about the show and it's all
about like the people that she grew up
like there's Sex in the City and there's
these other shows there's Gossip Girl
but like what about like my friends and
what happens when you graduate college
and you go to New York City and you're
trying to figure things out like I've
never seen that on television those are
the those are the people that I relate
to my generation Etc that are kind of
have been overlooked in the media
landscape and you know I'm sure a big
reason why that show is so special is
because it was telling those stories
that had yet been told yeah I mean she
always thought it was funny to have
people
who feel like they're owed the world so
they get out of college and they think
here it comes life is about to be handed
to me on a silver platter and then
nothing goes right and they're not as
smart as they thought they were the jobs
don't come as easily and that's what she
found hilarious about you know that
premise and and all the weird
relationships and friendships that you
have at that time in your life yeah
um in terms of of you you mentioned like
you like to write to whatever you're
going through or you know kind of
staring in the mirror looking at your
neuroses or whatever kind of issue
you're trying to you know work your way
through
um I know that that like self-help books
and all that kind of stuff has been you
know kind of a touchstone uh in terms of
how you think about this stuff and try
to develop characters out of what you're
reading like what is how is that played
into your work like what are the I mean
I I texted
um Pete Holmes earlier and I was like
I'm going to talk to Judd he's like he
loves Eckhart Tolle he's a deeply
virtual dude you know that's so funny uh
I think you know I I my history with
self-help is funny I remember my dad
when he was a younger man married to my
mom at some point read the Wayne Dyer
book your erogenous zones and then very
quickly after that my parents got
divorced
did you have like where they're like
Erica John Books laying around your
house or I'm okay you're okay yeah yeah
the early era of that uh I think that
was really the only book that was in the
house but it had an effect on my dad I
think maybe my mom went into therapy and
on the first day he said to me the
therapist went too hard at your mom and
so she won't go back and so so that was
the first time I heard about self-help
but when I was a kid I was home a lot my
my friends all played Sports and I
didn't and I would go home every day and
watch Donahue I would watch Phil Donahue
every day and would all these self-help
people would be on or just you know
shows about people's problems and
pre-opra era right and Stanley Siegel
was another guy who had a show like that
that was edgier and so it was always
interesting to me but then I met Gary
shanling and he introduced me to
Buddhism and he gave me this book a
feather on a fan and another one called
turning your problems into happiness and
that was the first time I paid any
attention to it as a as a young person
because my parents didn't really teach
me anything about any of it and it
wasn't really in the culture so I
probably should have gone to a therapist
as a teenager but no one did you know
what nobody was doing that and if you
and if you were to go it was
pathologized I mean you were something
there was something tremendously broken
about you it's funny looking back as I
you know I graduated high school in 85.
back then I mean I really don't remember
one person who went to a therapist there
was nobody
out of the closet uh you know our school
couldn't have been less diverse on Long
Island and there was just so much we
didn't know anything about that right we
just it's it's like when David Sedaris
uh writes about the fact that he went to
a speech therapist where he just
realized that everyone there was gay
right that's what it that's what it was
like back then like people weren't tuned
into who you were and how to help you
with your problems and it was a big deal
when Kramer versus Kramer came out or
terms of India we're like oh my God
these are movies that are dealing with
you know challenging emotions right it's
sort of like it was like a watershed
like we don't talk about that stuff I
just watch creamer versus creamer yeah I
can't say it fully holds up it's really
rough on Meryl Streep I mean you watch
it through the lens of today
and it it's like the
great ending the triumphant ending is
that the kid leaves his mom to stay with
the dad and she gives up her child
yeah that would not get Greenland yeah
today I don't think but uh but that's
what you did right you well you stayed
with your dad I was with your parents my
mom moved out and I just wanted to stay
in the same town uh-huh I didn't I
didn't want to leave and I just thought
I don't care what you do I'm staying in
this house like my friends are here
you're not gonna separate me right so it
wasn't a choice of parents as much as
location yes yeah and and that
consistency just the and the consistency
of my of my friends and it was you know
middle of Junior High School it was a
funny time because everyone's parents
got divorced at some point during our
childhood literally no there were no
kids whose parents can get divorced and
in our neighborhood
it was pretty upper middle class middle
class in most of the town uh and then
you would your parents would get
divorced and then you would move into an
apartment complex right down the street
literally like a mile away you'd see
like oh look they moved into uh Hidden
Ridge that's where we moved and that's
how you knew that that people's parents
got divorced yeah it was an interesting
time because it was sort of the first
era where there was acceptance around
divorce but all those people Got Married
Too Young in an era in which you're just
expected to get married as soon as you
graduate college or you know your high
school sweetheart or whatever I was
looking at a picture of my parents
wedding
this week and I would it was a party and
I literally thought it was my mom's
sweet 16. right they're they just
they're so young and they're like no
this is their engagement party
they met in summer camp uh but yes it
was just a different time and no one
knew how to talk about anything you know
my dad when my parents uh split up
you know I I was living with him it was
just me and him for a while and I saw a
book it was called growing up divorced
and I picked it up and looked at it and
it was kind of helpful it was like
explaining what the parents were going
through and I never talked to my dad
about it I just thought it was like some
book that he had that should deal with
me he sort of placed it there quietly
yeah he placed it there but but I said
to my Dad recently when I realized that
he placed it there
because I said to him once you never
talked to me about
how it was going my feelings you never
explain anything to me and I think he
thought the good thing that I'm doing is
I'm not going to you know to war with
your mom you know she's mad at me but
I'm not going to say anything bad about
her but we didn't really talk
emotionally because I don't think people
really knew how back then so he left out
this book and talked recently said to
him but you never asked me if I read the
book
so just because like I moved it maybe I
would have read one page like don't you
think you should have followed up and
said well I mean there's a lot of a lot
of threads he could have pulled you know
what I mean like I'm sure in his mind
he's like look what I did you know like
that's you know the book's in his room
right he's fine now I don't have to ask
him if he's depressed
uh oh that's amazing but to me that's
hilarious like that's comedy right like
I think it's so funny and I I I've tried
to figure out how to tell that in stand
up I've never really worked it out but
that is what I find funny about life I
think you're a kid your parents are
getting divorced they're at War your dad
doesn't want to communicate with you he
leaves a book out at a coffee table and
then never ever asked you until you're
like 50 years old if you picked it up
and what did you what did he say when
you finally raise it with him he's like
I figured you wrote it but I'm like but
you don't know it's like yeah but uh I
saw that you you took it
uh you Meanwhile your mom I read that
like the so she worked in this Comedy
Club but you didn't find out until later
that she actually took that job
out of uh you know this understanding
that she had about what you were
interested in well I assumed that it's
nothing that she ever said or I ever
asked about but I'm sure it's the case
because
you know my mom was so mad when her and
my dad split up she really like enjoyed
her middle class life and playing tennis
and taking care of the kids and suddenly
you know she's in the middle of this
divorce and she has to get a job and she
everything about her life changed her
parents were both after being very
wealthy were also having serious
financial problems and so she waited
tables she sold ads in a at a radio
station but my mom was hilarious because
she really didn't want to do any of it
like you know she she would just say
like this is a nightmare you know she
wasn't like I'm really learning about
hard work and connecting with new people
and it's really putting me in in a new
space which I'm enjoying it was just
like this sucks right upper middle class
to single mom yeah work and uh I didn't
really understand it until
years later you know close to when she
died uh we started talking for Real
about some of it about 12 years ago and
then after she died my aunt told me that
my grandfather would be on the road he
was a jazz producer and he would leave
for a week or weeks at a time and he
would always come back and bring her a
dress
and he he did that because he felt bad
about leaving and in a way love became
presence became materialism and so my
mom had that thing where she it meant a
lot to her to have a nice pair of shoes
and I never understood it my whole life
like I you know I would lent her money
once and
she she would get a like a she'd lease
like a Mercedes but then she'd have no
food to eat right and I'd say why don't
why didn't you get like a Camry and she
said because I'm not an animal
and it was like that was her in a
nutshell but I didn't understand that it
was really connected to love is
materialism it's a these gifts uh how uh
that's what her makeup was and so now
she's in Southampton
living in a guest house uh of of someone
because she can't afford anything but a
guest house and
she takes this job
seeding people at a comedy club
because my parents owned a restaurant
and the the bartender laughed and he
became an owner of comedy clubs and then
he was Tim Allen's manager and Drew
Carey and he became very successful but
at that time he had just started opening
up some comedy clubs and
I always thought how much could they
have paid her I mean what do you get
paid in 1983
to seat people for a few hours it's just
at night it's not even like a full-time
job
and and then I thought she must have
done it because she knew I wanted to see
that world right consciously or
unconsciously it was almost the most
important moment in my life that my mom
took that and so for one summer I could
go to every show all summer
go see Paul provenza and Jay Leno and
all of these people and
someone showed me there was some
pictures of the club
and I literally found a picture of a
show that I was at it was Paul provenza
and he had taken a giant umbrella and he
he was doing impression of E.T in the
woods turning like an umbrella into a
satellite dish and I was like I was in
the back of the room when this photo was
taken in 1983 and so I'm always very
thankful to my mom and to my dad who
drove me to comedy clubs at night I mean
he when I was in high school I started
doing stand-up and he would drive me to
Chuckles and Mineola and come and pick
me up in the middle of the night so they
always as much as they weren't getting
along both of them believed I could
succeed they'd never had any doubt and I
think that their belief that this was
worth doing made me confident enough to
take big risks
we're brought to you today by Roka
glasses are not something you normally
think about as a piece of performance
gear which when you think about it is
kind of insane because you can't perform
at your best if you can't see well the
Geniuses at Roka basically rebuild
eyewear from the ground up no matter how
active you are or how much you sweat
these things never slip or fall off your
face they're super durable they look
awesome and they've got tons of super
classy modern styles to choose from I've
been rocking rokas for about four years
at this point I love them I'm a big fan
of the Hamilton style and gloss black
that's this Frame right here as well as
clear or I guess they call them vintage
on the website and if you want to try
them out for yourself you can do that
right now and unlock 20 off your order
with the code richroll
roca.com or you can click the link in
the description below okay back to the
show
it's really beautiful you know that's a
like a what a what a gesture on your
mom's part and then that belief that
your parents had in you like this kid
who knew very early on what he wanted to
do what he was obsessed with I mean
that's a that could be a gift and a
curse that's something I'd be curious to
ask you about to have that conviction at
such a young age about what you wanted
to do with your life
um but to have that support and not be
not have parents trying to talk you out
of it or you should be a dentist or yeah
you know like that's the more typical
you know don't do this comedian you know
comedians right like that's a tough road
um
but to have that you know
to have that like vote of confidence in
your parents so when you
reflect back on your life from where you
sit right now do you reflect back on it
and think my life is a dream or I can't
believe I'm here or do you feel some
sense of of like inevitability or pre
yeah of course I'm here I deserve to be
here my parents believed in me I had the
conviction to do it I worked hard
yes I own this I own this spot like
where does the where does the the
confidence and the ego like crash into
the neurosis and you know what I mean
like what does that like stew look like
well comedy was the only place that I
ever felt really
confident it's the only place right and
there was never a plan B there was no
plan B yeah there's never let me I just
thought there's there's some place for
me in this world maybe I'll be a writer
maybe I'll be a comedian maybe I'll act
maybe I'll direct I I just knew there's
there's got to be something but you know
back then
there were 50 comedy clubs in the
country and no one in my high school
wanted to be in comedy so I thought and
comedy is not was not like it is now you
know it's not there's this industrial
complex
there's no internet yeah yeah there's no
podcasts I mean now all the comedians
are playing you know
Arenas then it was like just Steve
Martin and there weren't that many clubs
and so he really felt like oh there's
room for me in this world it was
accessible yeah and then no one else was
interested in it you know so I thought
I'm kind of lame in high school
but this thing that I'm interested in
that no one else is interested in I know
it's cool yeah but no one here thinks
it's cool even one of my friends said to
me
at some point in the last 10 years I
finally get what you were doing back
then now like yeah now I know why you're
that long yeah now I know why you were
watching the dinosaur show every day and
Merv Griffin like no one really got it
but that made me feel like okay there's
a there's a place for me in this space
and then I moved to LA and I met all the
other people in comedy and suddenly I
had all these friends who had basically
lived the same life as me in their
little town yeah and there was no
subreddit though where you guys can all
like chat about your weird Obsession
that no one else had no you'd have to
show up at a comedy club and do Open Mic
nights and you'd meet all the aspiring
comedians I used to start out you know I
started out with people like Doug Benson
and Andy Kindler and you know we would
just go to the clubs every night and I
met you know Adam Sandler and Rob
Schneider and David Spade and Jim Carrey
and that was our our world and our our
crew back then and we all had the same
dream and also the same path to do it
which is write jokes during the day get
on stage see if they worked every night
maybe that set will be a little bit
better and then maybe one night someone
important will see you do it and that
was the whole path of Comedy which I
loved that it was that simple like get
funny get noticed and it seemed very
fair
you know none of us really had any
advantage it was just we had to make Bud
Friedman like us so he'd put us on stage
at The Improv and then if he did maybe
The Tonight Show would show up or maybe
they'd put us on evening in The Improv
and it was really fun it was like
running you know like a race with all
your friends
it happened I mean the way it appears it
looks like it all happened pretty
quickly for you I mean you move out to
LA you go to USC for a year two years
year and a half year and a half
drop out move in with Adam Sandler do
you just met him at the comedy clubs or
how did that like happen I met him at
the comedy at the comic strip one night
and then then he moved to LA and I met
him when he first moved out to LA and he
had just graduated NYU and it's funny
because I was at USC my parents couldn't
afford my tuition I wasn't doing well
because I
I got there when I was 17 and I was in
over my head and I was very immature and
creatively I hadn't even begun to
understand anything
and then I went on The Dating Game and I
won so they said you have to go on this
trip to Acapulco which happened in
December during like the last two weeks
of finals and I couldn't afford to go to
school anymore I was tired of begging my
parents to try to figure out how to get
the tuition so I just went to Acapulco
and quit college
I just was like just bailed so hard at
the whole thing what was the impulse to
go on the dating show though do you just
went and stood in that line like by the
studio or how does it you know like back
then that's just something fun to do I
think we were all scouted that the shows
like that would want comedians young
Comedians and I wasn't a good comedian
at that point but they just wanted
people who were comfortable with
themselves on those shows and but that's
how I felt at the time like this is not
working here at school and I can't
afford it and everyone here seems way
better at me than this than I am and so
I did that and said okay I'm just going
to focus full time on stand up and then
you know a couple years later I met Adam
and you know we were doing the the same
thing just trying to figure out how to
be funnier yeah it was an interesting
time I feel like that period
was an inflection point in comedy and
how the entertainment industry sort of
interfaced with comedy in a similar way
to you think of these like places and
periods of time that are special like
Seattle in 1992 or like what would have
been like to live in downtown New York
when David Byrne was you know like like
where you know there's like a certain
energy you know something's happening
that's interesting and
um did you have a sensibility like oh
this is like there's something cool
going on that that like
contemporaneously with this community
and kind of culture at large and that's
meeting up with like my obsession that's
creating a potential energy or were you
just like I don't care I'm here I love
this stuff I'm just meeting these people
and trying to work it out I think
somewhere in me was the dream of
you know having a community like
Saturday Night Live always felt like a
community like oh they're old friends I
mean maybe they weren't but in your head
you'd watch the show or you'd see Monty
Python or second City TV and they had
these these groups and so the idea of
finding your people and you know working
in the thing that you love was very
appealing to me I don't know if at the
time we really understood how well so
many people were going to do
looking back it seems kind of crazy Rob
Schneider lived across the street from
me and Adam and down the street was
David Spade and over the hill you know
Jim Carrey who was ahead of us by a
bunch of years uh but you know was just
coming back to stand up after having a
movie and a TV show not do well and he
was trying to figure out who he was as a
creative voice you know these were the
people that we were around and then you
know one by one people got these
opportunities and then people did really
well and it was
so fun I mean me and Adam looked back on
it and we just talk about like was the
greatest time ever we're very nostalgic
about it I mean we'll we'll talk on the
phone and go oh remember when we went to
Red Lobster that time
we were so excited we could afford Red
Lobster
um so there's those videos of him
crankcalling people yeah that is what
our life was like we didn't have jobs so
way too much time was spent doing goofy
things like making phony phone calls
because we didn't have an outlet for our
creativity and Adam had so much Chi he
had so much energy to be funny so he
would be he would he'd be funny with you
he'd be funny with anyone around because
it was just there yeah and there had to
be a sense of inevitability with him
though like everybody must have known
like there's just there were certain
people you just knew thought this is
unlimited what could happen here and it
hasn't happened much since then but
certainly at the time
Adam and Jim Carrey at least in my mind
and in a lot of people's minds were
going to be yeah they're just stars in
the world yeah even when they were
bombing even when it wasn't going well
you would just see them up there and go
that there's something magical in what
they're doing and their personality and
their their Charisma and they're also
the two of the hardest working people of
everyone they did outwork everybody
hmm I knew that about Carrie I didn't
know that about Adam Sandler though I
mean Adam was writing screenplays for
himself
uh immediately before he had any jobs
before he even had a decent job when he
was just happy to get a commercial he
was writing a screenplay with my friend
Joel Madison who lived down the street I
mean
there was a sense of I need to learn how
to do this and so and then a bunch of us
did that I wrote a pilot no one really
wanted me to write a box we just started
writing we're like I think we need to
learn how to write and we saw some
people succeed around us like Jim Carrey
with Ace Ventura and we noticed oh Jim
and Tom shady I found the script and
they rewrote it and they created an
opportunity for themselves they didn't
wait to get cast They yeah they were
like I know these guys this is doable
yeah
it's what I preach to everyone like
you're gonna you have most of them you
have to write your future and you have
to show people what you do
so when I worked with you know Jason
Siegel and he talks about it all the
time I just you know he he this becomes
like a story he tells but it is true I
said you know you're you're you're a
weird guy you're funny and you're you're
super unique and people aren't just
gonna hand you a script that captures
that you need to write it and then he
wrote Forgetting Sarah Marshall was the
first screenplay you ever wrote yeah but
it was so true to him and he understood
himself in a way that nobody else ever
could have and so we all were trying to
figure out
how to do that right
um the community piece seems to loom
large for you like everything that you
that you've done and your best work is
all about this sort of Esprit de corps
and and trying to kind of recapture what
it was like living with Adam and that
apart you know like just having a lot of
cool funny people around all the time
and you know the the sort of lore the
Mythos of Saturday Night Live is that
that's what that is right so you know
it's it is you would have fit in well
with that I think as a writer
um oh but short of that like you
recreating that in in other ways yeah I
mean Adam you know one day Adam just
says I'm going to Chicago to
audition for Saturday Night Live uh-huh
he didn't like do characters they just
saw him do stand up and then afterwards
a few days he's like yeah I'm leaving so
suddenly I'm in the apartment by myself
yeah that air is over I mean that did I
move out do I stay in this apartment and
I don't you know kept paying rent for a
while and then slowly I was like I guess
I should leave I live alone he's not
coming back I talked to him yesterday
because he left his wallet on the Mark
Twain Awards I showed his driver's
license because he literally left his
driver's license and his fake ID that he
had when he was a kid
but yesterday I was just going through
some stuff and I found his wallet which
had a receipt from Ralph's Supermarket
and I just looked at it because this is
what Adam just bought his groceries it
was literally chocolate pudding and
Frosted Flakes it was the most fun you
still have this yeah I just I just
because I always thought it was funny
that he left his wallet not only did he
leave his voice fake ID I have a fake
idea is that he never asked if it was
there he didn't just leave it he never
said did I leave my wallet I mean that's
how forward thinking he was he just
moved to a new city with no ID and
started his new life I never looked back
at all I left most of his clothes but um
so then I you know we would all help
each other and you know try to help Adam
write sketches and then hope that one
day we could get hired and some of us
did get hired Tim Hurley who who wrote
you know most of the Adams movies uh
with Adam uh who is as funny as anybody
ever you know he got a job there he was
a lawyer and he left to write for
Saturday Night Live he was Adam's
roommate in college and then I had a
packet and I was trying to get in I just
never got in and then Jim I was helping
Jim write some sketches for a Living
Color and then I did a meeting to try to
get a job
there so then I met Ben Stiller and we
created the Ben Stiller show
and that's how I got into the sketcho
because I couldn't get a staff job and
then just through just this weird
uh
moment where I bumped into Ben Stiller
who I didn't know and but people were
interested in him doing a sketch show
and we just thought of an idea for it
and two weeks later we sold it people
thought that we were friends forever we
had met two weeks before wow and so
without really any
useful experience
you know I was right helping Ben right
that really get you know sort of kicks
off you and like everything that follows
you know that show how many seasons did
that go it didn't go very long right one
or two oh only 13 episodes yeah you know
up against
60 minutes and all the commercials that
we shot we wrote all these commercials
was Ben playing an agent and he was
talking to different celebrities in the
different commercials and telling them
not to go on the Ben Stiller show
because it's definitely gonna get
canceled because it's up against 16
minutes yeah I mean our ad campaign was
predicting our cancellation which
followed uh soon after but that's where
you know we worked with Bob Odenkirk and
Andy Dick yeah cheating Garofalo and
that's really where I learned most of
the first stuff that I needed to learn
how to do this was was from Ben who had
already done a sketch show for MTV and
it was brilliant it had a real Vision
right about what he wanted comedy to
look like he wanted to do these
cinematic sketches it's interesting to
see what he's doing now I mean you know
it's with Severance like you know in
your in your in your deck for something
that he you know he would be interested
in doing like so cinematic so weird and
and kind of heavy on the drama and you
know uh dannemora like these serious you
know cinematic shows that he's working
on no he's uh
he's really fulfilling all the potential
yeah you know that he had because back
then you know he was developing Reality
Bites and Danny DeVito was one of the
producers and he said you know you're
doing this SketchUp you should really go
nuts with the camera and really learn
how to be a director and then Ben did he
did these sketches like this tjo
pootertudes Twilight Zone type episode
The David Crossroad and and he he pushed
himself and now you know he's uh like
Cindy Lou matter I know it's crazy I
mean you could see Bill Hader doing that
too with the stuff that he's doing in
Barry you know you can see that
trajectory and we always say to people
hey
if you have your own show really push to
direct it because it's not impossible to
do you could really learn how to be a
great director Aziz anzari uh directed a
lot of Masters of none and has become an
amazing director and Amy Schumer's done
a lot of directing and it's great so I
think that's what we all look for
opportunities to figure out how to do
that next step I learned at the Larry
Sanders show Gary let me direct an
episode and then when we did Freaks and
Geeks is when I really started right
doing a bunch of it I want to talk about
Gary but you know looking at your your
IMDb I mean it's you know it's 100 miles
long
um there's so many movies we can't talk
about all your movies but if I kind of
glance at it at 10 000 feet what what
jumps out at me is this period between
around
2004 to 2015 where it's just an insane
amount of output like just an incredible
number of it's a nervous breakdown like
you know 15 movies or something you know
like just TV shows movies producer
writer director Etc
um and I can't help but think
despite it being like just an absolute
tear uh that there has to be some level
of like obsessive workaholicism in that
like like what was your life like for
that 10-year period where you were
hitting your stride and like just the
output was like Beyond
you know I'm only beginning now to have
any perspective about it I do think that
when
you're younger you have
like a ridiculous amount of
belief in yourself that is completely
unwarranted
and that I think it's almost in your
genetic makeup to take risks and to LEAP
in
and when I look back I I think yeah I
mean there was a moment of
feeling like
we were all in a crazy Groove but also
being very collaborative with each other
we were all reading each other's scripts
and giving notes and going to table
reads and you know there was uh there
really was a community there so if there
was a table read we all would go right
and you would get notes from everybody
and I remember the 40 year old virgin
table read and Adam McKay was there and
he's like you know when they're talking
maybe they should all be like hitting
each other with fluorescent lights I
used to do that when I worked at this
place you put it in or
uh you know Gary Shanley would come to
the table read and give remarkable notes
way deeper than than we knew how to do
and and you know he would tell us what
the core emotional ideas were that we
needed to pay attention to
and I recently found in Gary stuff the
script for the 40 year old version with
Gary's notes all throughout so he called
me with his notes but I found the actual
script and he said you know it's this is
about love this is about the fact that
he falls in love and and because he's in
love his sex is better than all of his
friends sex
right and he's like you have to find a
way to to show that and I I didn't know
how to do it because I'm like I can't
end it with just like the greatest sex
scene
but as a friend we were all there for
each other and a lot of ways you know
still are but more you know distant
because people have their own worlds and
and new people they they work with that
all happened in the in the normal
natural way but for a while you know
almost like a music scene everyone was
in Seattle yeah and I think it helped
all of us you know Seth and Evan you
know we're producers in addition to Seth
acting in the movies so they would be
there right for all the punch-ups and
all the creative conversations and and
um you know I produced movies for you
know a lot of people and then friends
who had nothing to do with it would come
and just pitch yeah and help and I
remember uh
we did a Pineapple Express table read
and
people had such incredible notes uh one
friend of ours was like this is about
the fact that Seth Rogen doesn't know if
he wants to be friends with his dealer
but his dealer really wants to be
friends with him and he was in there but
we didn't really know that that's what
it was about and as soon as someone
unlocks like the whole movie yeah then
suddenly the whole movie was funny
because this one friend said this is
what you just wrote right and and so it
was definitely a really special time and
I think
you know I had two young daughters and I
you know I was working and Leslie was
working but I also made a point of
trying to shoot almost all of it in town
sometimes down the street you know one
movie we shot on our block so there was
a real real intention to not be the dad
that disappears right so we shot Walk
Hard in town and knocked up and 40 year
old virgin and funny people I mean we
you people don't usually shoot movies in
LA because it's cheaper out of town and
whatever power we had we used a lot of
it to stay in L.A yeah yeah and be
normal human beings yeah it's
interesting I mean you know
a typical perspective on Hollywood is
you know Cutthroat everybody's stabbing
each other in the back everybody's lying
to you they're telling you what they
want to hear it's like this sort of like
a succession sort of situation where you
know you can't trust anybody
um everybody's you know screwing around
on their partners and spouses and all of
that and you're a guy who's you know
making tons of movies and TV shows
living a pretty traditional fan you know
like you know child of divorce
clearly you know went into your marriage
with a commitment to do it differently
and you've been with your wife forever
and you have two daughters that you know
it it appears that you have great
relationships with and you've been able
to have like a you know really kind of
conventional family upbringing in an
insane Town while doing tons of work
with a perspective that
um you know the pie is unlimited like
the best idea wins let's do this as a
community as a family uh bring more
people in like that is that you know
that that sort of like camaraderie team
approach I think would surprise people
who have like a projected idea of what
it's like to make a movie in Hollywood
everybody does it differently this came
organically out of
Freaks and Geeks and Undeclared where we
met all these people the shows were
canceled but we all felt like we haven't
really tapped this
and we knew that so many of the people
involved were special and not just the
actors the production designer Jeff Sage
who did under you know Undeclared and
Freaks and Geeks did tons of movies with
us and and still does and just people in
all positions Russ also Brooke our DP on
Freaks and Geeks you know did Forgetting
Sarah Marshall and uh and did uh you
know super bad and
and so we just wanted to keep working
together right and so the traveling
circus that doesn't leave town yeah and
I encourage everyone to write and oddly
they did and so
but when you look at at the cast of
Freaks and Geeks and Undeclared you know
obviously you have this Keen Eye for
emerging Talent or who would be good or
you see Lena I know you came into that
project later
um
and and you know keeping those people
close and sort of fostering their
careers and believing in them in a way
that uh you know I can't help but think
was your relationship with Gary
Shandling
right like this idea you meet him very
young he gives you this job to write
jokes for the for the great it was the
Grammys right was that the first thing
um and he plays this incredibly powerful
role in your life as as like a mentor
like just a just a force of nature so
talk a little bit about like I'm
interested in the kind of mentorship
piece and how you think about returning
the incredible you know sort of
um favor that he did for you with all
the young people that you work with
well I met Gary doing stand-up with him
at the comedy magic club and my manager
Jimmy Miller was like hey Gary you
should use use Judd to write you some
jokes and Gary didn't seem to show any
interest and then a few months later I
got a call he's hosting the Grammys and
he needs jokes and I was at the Improv
in Tempe Arizona and I just stayed up
all night and wrote like 100 jokes I
just thought I need to write enough
jokes so I'm indispensable to him and in
the morning we went through the jokes on
the phone and we just got along great he
rewrote every single joke but I think I
was presenting ideas that Lit him up so
here's the premise here's a setup and
then he would just top the punch line
every single time but I think it really
worked for him and I understood music
and what all the issues were he didn't
really know that much about music and
then he invited me to go to the show and
to be there for rehearsals and be on
stage during the show giving him jokes
and then we became very close friends
and then that becomes like
you know a fantasy come true I
interviewed him when I was in high
school right after he uh hosted The
Tonight Show for the first time before
he did a TV show and
[Music]
the fact that he would let me hang
around with him and suddenly like
I'd go over his house and have dinner
with him and his girlfriend Linda and
we'd watch TV and then he was riding the
Larry Sanders show and he would let me
read the drafts and he was casting it
and he would show me tapes and I would
open up for him on the road sometimes I
opened up when he shot his HBO special
and there was a part of me that's like
why is this guy so nice to me
and as someone who came from a divorce
it was very impactful for me because
it's someone that had my interest was
the best in the world at it who wanted
to teach me and created a home for you
yeah it was very kind of a person yeah
and uh you know became just a really
close close friend
and I tried to come through for him so
if he needed writing done I really
worked hard and but I also think I
understood him and I think some people
didn't understand him I think he was a
very unique neurotic person and for
whatever reason probably just having
similarities in complicated moms
something like that yeah yeah I just
spoke his language
I wasn't anywhere near as talented as
him I don't think I was providing him
with something that came close to what
he could do at that time
but I was I was a good hang and I was a
good sounding board and I helped him
stir the pots and he said something
funny I wrote it down and wouldn't lose
it so that's a big that's underrated
sale that's a big skill when you're with
funny people because they're funny all
day long but they let it all disappear
into the ether so if you're the person
that goes remember you said that thing
and it's a great joke you know that's
that's a real a real gift and
the thing about Gary is he continued to
do that so
I did the schedule with Ben I asked him
if he would be on the pilot doing a
cameo and he said yes which I think is
part of the reason why he got picked up
him and Roseanne and Tom were in the
pilot and it made us look like we really
were connected when we really didn't
know that many people we just got
everyone we knew on the pilot right
um then he hosted an episode of the
Stiller show or was the guest on one of
the shows and at the same time he was
doing Larry Sanders show and that's how
he he mentioning Garofalo because I was
showing him tapes of her and then he put
her on the Larry Sanders show yeah and
then Bob Odenkirk was on the Larry
Sanders show so there was a lot of cross
pollination right right happening and
then he then when my show got canceled
he said why don't you come work for me
he's like you're gonna learn you'll
learn a lot and he and I always say he
didn't
he didn't say
you're going to be so helpful to me he
said you're going to learn a lot but
over the course of five or six years I
got better and then he asked me to
direct and he asked me to run the show
with Adam Resnick the last
season and so he continued to give me
opportunities and believe in the next
stage of my career he didn't ask anyone
else to direct the show
uh that wrote for the show when I look
back at that now that's crazy because
they were some of the great comedy
writers of all time there but he had
some Instinct that I could do it and
then when I started directing elsewhere
he'd read the script he'd look at the
cuts I mean it's harder now honestly
without him I have to really imagine
that I'm talking to him and I just
finished a script and I really thought
like okay this is just right like it's
an episode of the Larry Sanders show
just think just put it through the Gary
filter right be tough on it the way Gary
would be ask the questions Gary would
ask or go back and read his journals
about exactly thought about his own work
yeah and what is it what are these
stories really about what what kind of
lessons are in there because like to
Gary underneath the satire was him
exposing all the ways people have
trouble connecting and all the masks we
wear and and how hard it is to be close
to people when you're insecure and
broken or when you're very ambitious and
I I try to get his you know his his
voice in my head and and I can you know
in most situations if I think about what
Gary would say
I usually think I'm pretty close yeah
um I love the documentary that you that
you made about him and uh I think he was
you know on the one hand like in terms
of his work like so pioneering not just
in how he thought about stand up and the
evolution of how he kind of arrived at
his style which was to be himself and to
be authentic and to try to find those
specific things that he was going
through that would connect with the
universal that obviously is influential
in your work but also Reinventing and
reimagining the form of television in
that original sitcom like it's it's Gary
Shandling show or whatever where he was
breaking the fourth wall and then in and
then in um
and then at the uh the show that you
worked on with him over the years like
you know does Curb Your Enthusiasm
happen without that like you know like
the ripple effect of like him
sort of pushing the envelope of what
television could be
um I think is probably underestimated
not to you but uh maybe a lot of people
and then beyond that just the impact
that he had on people personally
obviously like this hugely important
figure for you but you're not alone like
he impacted a lot of people like when he
Pat I mean it was like you know all of
Hollywood you know there were so many
people who have so many stories about
how he touched them in really meaningful
ways with his
um
you know desire to be connected and and
to be helpful and to be this sort of
mentor and the undercurrent of of kind
of spirituality that he you know brought
to his work and to other people that I
guess began when he had this near-death
experience in this car accident when he
was young yeah he was he got into a
fender bender and he got out to look at
the damage and a car hit one of the cars
in the fender bender and he got crushed
between the two cars and had to have his
gallbladder removed and he had one of
those stories where he said
during the operation I looked down and I
saw everything that was happening and
there was a white light and I walked to
it and they said you want to continue
living Gary shandling's life
and he said yes and then the next day he
could say what happened in the room and
as neurotic as he was he didn't seem to
have a fear of death that's what is so
fascinating about Gary because he's
still more afraid of commitment than
that yeah really right like afraid of
engulfing and afraid of losing his
freedom
um afraid of being with the wrong person
by accident and yet you know there were
journals where he was heading into you
know life-threatening surgeries
and he's he's very courageous and he you
know he writes in his journal
um
if you live another year be grateful if
you live another day be grateful
and that's what I love about the
documentary because because Gary on some
levels is such a mess
the beauty of someone like him working
so hard to understand himself to grow
and then to get to a place of just
wanting to be grateful and to give to
other people on another on another page
in his in his journal that said uh
uh give give with no hope of getting
anything in return
and those were things that he was
writing to himself
to try to make himself believe them yeah
and to try to live them but just the
fact that he was trying and he did walk
the walk in a lot of ways where he was
giving to me and to a lot of people and
he you know maybe in relationships he
never quite figured that out
uh but he was really trying and then you
know he got sick and I think he was
diminished in some way his near the end
of his life and and had some some
problems but you know when I went
through all
the emails from him after he died every
single time I asked him if he could help
me with something he said yes can you go
to this thing yes and like it was
literally a hundred times wow every
single time what time and
that's the thing as a mentor I I took
from him I tried to take both from the
bad stuff like don't do that or try not
to torture yourself in that way and I I
tried to learn from the the great things
that he did so for me it it mentoring
people I don't even think I ever thought
about it other than it just seemed like
that's what you do it's like if you're
like a baby and you know to breastfeed
and then you have a baby and you know
okay now I'm I'm the breastfeederer like
I guess that's how it works right like
people help me and now it's my job to
collaborate and help other people and
you know the main reason I I always do
it and did it is because I like it I
just I'm impressed with creative people
I love the collaboration I love the
Friendship of it yeah it's not like I
mean it's a noble effort yeah like being
a supporter feels like that's your
design naturally yeah it's not like
you're you have to force yourself to no
I know that costume and it's not like
isn't it so great that I'm doing this or
aren't I a great person for doing this
because I don't think it really works
that way I think you're entering into a
collaboration it's like starting a band
with each person
and so you're like all right should I
play drums on this one you play guitar
on that one and that's really what it is
I'm giving as much as I'm getting
sometimes I'm getting more you know that
I'm giving from the experience or the
work I I'm playing a small role in the
work maybe I'm just getting this thing
made but someone's doing all the the
creative work yeah so each situation is
very unique right but is there like when
you're writing a script and you're
thinking what would Gary say or how
would what would his notes be do you
think what would Gary do in this
situation when you know somebody calls
me and says do you have you know 15
minutes where I can run an idea by you
know some young you know writer or
something yeah you try to be generous
with your with your time yeah I mean
when you think about Legacy and this is
a legacy obsessed town right what are
the projects that are gonna live beyond
you
Etc uh and then you reflect on Gary
shanling's Legacy I mean his legacy is
is the impact how he made people feel I
mean he has this great body of work but
really what people talk about and Revere
about him is the time that he invested
in all of these people out of the
kindness of his heart
absolutely I mean that is the the the
main impact of his life I mean he
inspired people and in the documentary
everyone at The Simpsons was like it's
Gary Shandling show was where many of
those right started yeah exactly and
they said like he showed us
how far you can go how creative you can
be and it lit up their imaginations you
know the other person that was a
important mentor to me was David milch
who created Deadwood and co-created NYPD
Blue with Stephen bochko and he was
another one that you know everybody
talks I mean reveres him as a genius
I mean it's ridiculous you watch the
ultimate television writer yeah and you
watch Deadwood and it's a different kind
of Genius because sometimes you watch
things and you think I could do
something
in the universe of that and when you
watch Deadwood you think there's no
chance that me or anyone else on Earth
could do this it's just under completely
different level but David Milt she has
Alzheimer's now and so it's been a long
time you know since he found out and and
I go visit him and you know one day
I was talking to him and he said we
should write something together
and it's very emotional because you know
he's far down that road right and I said
what would he write and he said uh
something about someone in my situation
and I said well what would it be about
and he said regrets
and I said what what would he regret and
he goes failures of generosity
hmm and I literally it was hard to not
just
start crying hard right there but it was
a reminder that that's really all
that you're left with which is
you know how did I treat people how did
I treat myself was I good to the people
in my life how could I have been better
it was just a gift to even have that
right moment with him and he's talked
about that at other moments which is
that's that's his main concern is to be
a giving person and I think all of us as
creative people there's something so
self-involved about it and it it takes a
lot of your bandwidth and you're always
trying to figure out how do I balance
this how do I be a good parent how am I
available to the people in my life while
still doing this work which just sucks
so much out of you right
um
yeah when I look at that decade period
where you were a maniac
I'm sure you're thinking like I'm
creating all of these things and this is
what my life will will mean right or if
you're David Mill she was he was I mean
he's like a hard ass right like he was a
tough guy
well he he I mean I never worked with
him on those shows but he definitely
like a hard-boiled writer type dude I
mean he
you know he taught at Yale but he also
you know had a lot of issues with
addiction and and gambling and you know
he was one of those people that would he
would lay on the ground there'd be a
microphone on the ground
and he would dictate the show people
would wait around well he channeled
the show and he he believes he used to
say uh
inspiration comes to prepared souls and
his whole thing was about that
connection can you open yourself up and
be so present and available that the
creativity comes and to trust that and
I I learned so much from him about that
hmm you know to be in there you practice
that when you pair that with you know
Gary's uh passion for meditation and all
does that like trickle down into the it
does daily routine I try to I try to
understand it I you know I recently took
a flow course
you know Stephen Cotler I'm sure you've
had on you know has these online
programs about like flow research which
I highly recommend it was great but I
had this Instinct like oh I'm too
distracted
I need to get my focus back so I so I
did this online coursework and stuff
like that or uh
it's just explaining where the
distractions come from how to prevent
them and how to get into a state of flow
and how to stay there you know for a
while and to know how to give yourself a
break and get back to it just to really
understand how that works in your mind
and you know I've heard him on so many
of the podcasts talking about it I said
you know what what if I committed to
doing this and I've never done that my
whole life and they said and we have
coaches who you can speak with which I
did
and it was you know it was very simple
stuff but the stuff you just don't do
and and a lot of stuff that you've
talked about in a lot of podcasts you
know just wake up in the morning don't
check your phone just get your ass in
the chair yeah tell everyone not to
interrupt you for four hours uh take a
break every half an hour for five
minutes but don't go on your phone in
the break you know just all the things
interiorly and exteriorly which will
stop your creative right flow like you
can't necessarily manufacture a flow
state but you can create circumstances
yeah that make it make it conducive and
absolutely being in that state is like
the Holy Grail of a writer yeah it's
like when Bob Dylan talks about
you know a song just happened in 10
minutes well that's what that is right
uh there are moments in your life where
you can just see it like the screenplay
I just wrote I took a hike
I never do that I never take a hike it's
like rare and so I said I'm gonna take a
hike alone in like 30 minutes in like
the entire movie just came to me
and then I then I took this class
then I wrote the movie I mean I hadn't
written a movie alone in 10 years I've
been riding with other people because I
got lonely I got so bored of being alone
I said at this time I'm gonna write it
alone I'm gonna get used to being alone
again
and everything about the course
completely worked it was hilarious I
mean I'm making bad that it worked uh
well sometimes I think well you know
should I have been doing more writing
alone right I I really cherish those
times with the other people and the work
and the work oh yes I should hike more I
do I do take like a 90 minute walk like
four or five times a week but sometimes
I listen to a podcast and sometimes I go
I'm just going to do it in silence and
see what comes
or you know one of the David milch
things is to you know to to just start
writing you know he he always says uh
you can't think yourself into writing
but you can write yourself into thinking
so just start and it'll it'll just come
and so that was a a real lesson
for me you know like there are ways I
could be better at this that's why when
you get back to you know self-help you
know I'm always looking for something
that will make me
you know open up in some way heal in
some way learn something that will make
me more efficient and and sometimes I'm
drowning in self-help because I just
read it listens yeah that creates its
own paralysis yes yeah because I'm a
hoarder a bit so I'll I'll listen to too
much but with this I just said okay this
is this is really simple just get your
ass in the chair
amazing at it actually working yeah
because you're going how creative am I
do I have any jokes left in this brain
and to see it happen
uh was really rewarding and made me
think oh maybe I could do that three
more times this year how do you how do
you balance the collaborative aspect of
the the creation and writing process
versus that like
ass in a chair alone at home
you know what is the daily you know do
you set it up with a schedule well once
the script is done then I just send it
to everybody and just go what do you
think what do you think and then at some
point I'll sit alone and
you know or with a writer's assistant
and just rewrite it and then I try to
read it out loud and then then I can
watch it like a movie and see if it
works for me as a movie and then rewrite
it and read it out loud again and then
at some point if someone will let me
make it we go into rehearsals and then
it changes a lot once the actors bring
their stuff right into it
how do you know when you're when you
have an idea I think I asked you this
earlier but like that that you know it's
like once you commit to an idea there's
a long road ahead right
um is there like something does
something light up in your brain where
you're like this is it or this is the
thing like or is that an instinct or
uh you have an instinct but then you
just keep like telling it to people
and so you're like if they like it
yeah it seem funny you know it's just
like a movie about like
guy gets girl pregnant and
he hangs out with those Stone friends
and he's a nightmare but she wants to
see if maybe he could be a good
boyfriend and you know and then you then
you start showing the outline to some
friends and you're looking for some
reinforcement that you're not in a crazy
place and then
at some point you think
am I Really Gonna do this okay maybe
I'll write five pages
let me just see if it comes to life and
then usually you go oh yeah this seems
funny does it start generally with a
conceit for you or with a person like a
character like uh this this person what
would this person what Adventure would
this guy go on
uh I mean each each time is different
but I like working from some very
passionate idea or truthful idea you
know when Leslie and I uh
we should have word the hospital having
our second uh our uh second child just
everything went wrong uh other than
she's beautiful and healthy but the
doctor was mean the doctor was mean the
other doctor just didn't show up just
left town to go to a bar mitzvah and I I
just took notes that night I was like
this is so crazy
how weird this night is so in the back
of my head I'm like there's probably a
way to tell this story
and then you back into it you know
eventually uh you know with with Pete
Davidson with the king of Staten Island
we had worked in a different idea for a
while
and then usually it you just say what
should we really be writing about and
then it just comes out like are you
willing to explore what we probably
should explore and Pete was and so then
we started writing that version yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um the like knowing when you know it's
time to pull the thread a little bit
further versus moving on
and it's really hard to start a script
for me because I think one of the things
I always have to get over is by by
writing I'm finding out if I'm terrible
so it's very easy to not write because
if I don't write I won't find out if I'm
bad do you still go to war with yourself
in that way though I think so I think
it's subtle but it's just just because
you
it's just a little there's a critical
voice that you you are always wrestling
with that basically says just don't do
it just go watch TV like you don't have
to suffer through this and to try to
turn it into a pleasurable experience
I'm still almost in hyperventilation or
anxiety most of the time I'm actually
writing I'm just
I'm so nervous and I'm trying to like
open a spigot and I have to relax to let
it come out but there's just a weird
part of me that's just scared scared
it's gonna be bad scared I'm gonna that
like Stephen pressfield resistance
kind of thing it's totally that and and
that's what the flow thing helped me
with which is
you know I can toss it all I don't have
to I can throw out all of them I can
throw out all the work today just just
trust it might be there might be
something good like if you I wrote this
script kind of fast
and I just said I'm going to write
straight through to the end I'm not even
going to re-read yesterday's Pages until
I get to the end
and then I got to the end and then I
started reading it and I was like
I don't even remember writing almost
anything like I remember the story but
the language and the jokes
and I was really pleasantly surprised by
it but I I just forced myself to
to just go to you know that part of my
imagination and just followed wherever
it led me and that's not how I always
wrote I think I was more methodical and
I just thought maybe I'll just kind of
you know go into the trance and see yeah
make it sort of like morning Pages no
Stakes exactly but I did those
I mean the the Julie Cameron artist way
you know I I did that in the early 90s
yeah I think I started that in 90
when did that book come out
97 98 I mean I could have done that in
the no no because I did it in the early
90s yeah yeah you're right yeah I could
have even done a late 80s but
you know so that idea of morning Pages
didn't just write don't judge just
whatever comes out it doesn't matter
which was also David milch exercise
where he said to get your creative
juices going for two weeks right for 20
minutes a day
print it and then tear it up
just to get used to your brain being
creative and like the the Zen Buddhist
model sand mandala yeah yeah but he said
you'll you'll open up you know that part
of your brain and it'll fire up and I've
never done that but I understand what
he's just not going to be precious not
being too attached there's it's like
having a baby like suddenly your body
knows how to make a baby right like your
whole life is not making a baby then one
day like this machine builds itself and
you have a baby well there's a part of
your brain or your mind that you could
turn on and it builds itself to be
creative yeah if you just start doing it
there's something about consistency in
momentum also yeah build a little
momentum and then you're kind of then
suddenly there's something real about it
and then you're like oh this is a real
thing yeah and I always think if I'm on
page 60 I can finish finish it the
weekend wow I don't always do it in the
weekend but I think if I get to 60 I
could write 20 Pages a day for two days
and have a really shitty draft and then
I'll fix it up
how often do people ask you about when
you're gonna uh write this is 50.
people have been asking because it's
been on Netflix and and uh and I have an
idea for it oh you do and so you know
I'd have to sit down and do it which
I've thought about maybe trying to do
that before I shoot the next movie to
take a few buttons and and write that
and try to do that in a year or so
you're you're leaving so are you going
to work on something like you're leaving
town to go work or is that just oh I'm
going to London my daughter is uh oh in
Cabaret in the West End so that's what
you do when your kids move out is you
just go to where they are and just stalk
them
um we're in your office right now we're
in the middle of a strike yes
um you've shared thoughts and opinions
on what's going on right now but maybe
you could kind of explain
the the the the the conflict that's
happening right now between the writer's
Guild and the industry at Large
well when technology changes
the way people get paid needs to change
what is tricky about it is
for this industry it really only works
if the writers
can survive
so if if the way people are paid makes
it so the writers can't survive then the
writers won't be writers they'll
disappear and the way that writers
survive gig to gig is that in between
gigs they get paid for the reruns of
previous work and when that's not fair
Riders can't eat and then you know a lot
of these shows they're not 22 Episodes
anymore they're six or they're eight so
right there
a lot of people are not making what they
used to make because that means you have
to get two jobs a year or three jobs and
it never times out that you could fill
your year for most writers and and it's
a it's a big problem and it only gets
solved because the streamers want the
writers to be solid they have to have
the intention because if the writers
aren't working and getting residuals
money doesn't go into their health plans
and their pension plans and then
suddenly none of the writers have health
care or the actors have yeah health care
so hopefully they'll figure it out and
it's an exacerbation of what was already
lopsided in favor of the studios versus
the writers the writers have always been
sort of shortchanged it's it appears
like in this equation of being equitably
treated and it's a little bit different
whether you're talking about movies or
TV like in movies there there was always
home video and DVD and all these
ancillary markets foreign territories
Etc so all these revenue streams were
kind of percolating in over time and
then in television which Heralds the
writer a little bit better especially on
Big Shows than it does in movies
um they're you know you have these
showrunners there's it seems like
there's a little I'm interested in this
like there are like a lot of these
really big show Runners right who have
massive deals with streamers and
networks and Etc and then you have
Legions of writers who are you know
semi-employed sometimes employed Etc at
some point what is the political heft of
those showrunners who are like they can
wait it out they're getting paid plenty
of money
um to say you know enough's enough we
got to get back to work that's usually
how it ends is I mean Mike White's over
in Thailand right now sitting around you
know
interrupted in the middle of White Lotus
at some point HBO's got to go we gotta
we gotta we gotta get the show made
well I mean
I think people start noticing that
they're not getting anything but reality
shows and I think it
it probably affects stock prices at some
point when you go stranger things
doesn't come in anytime soon now and a
lot of these programs that everyone
loves and wait for
they're not in production so you hope
that this gets resolved before people
suffer a lot and the thing that always
frustrates me is whatever the solution
is they could have thought of it three
months ago there's nothing nothing you
would said and I think you're right like
they already know they already know what
they're going to settle for yeah they
know their numbers and so a lot of
people suffer a lot of the support
people in the community the restaurants
near the studios and you know people on
the on the cruise suffering they really
don't need to what the what the end
result of this will be will not be
shocking and and that's what the drag of
the whole thing is because it really is
unnecessary if they wanted to to solve
it they definitely could have and that's
what I think is awful but it is an
enormous amount of companies who have to
agree on the solution and some of these
companies they're not really
entertainment companies you know they're
computer companies that have a little
tiny entertainment business to them yeah
so I think it's much more complicated
and then they all say oh we're suffering
we're suffering but then all the heads
of the companies are making so much
money and you're like well
if you're getting paid that much I think
your business is working yeah you can't
save the business isn't working if you
could justify your salary so if the
business is working
then we're doing a good job too
but we're not actually being paid for
the job that we're doing you know you
know it's also about creativity you know
what people don't like to talk much
about is like all the metadata leads you
to a very Bland place there's a reason
exactly what people are watching how
long they're watching when they tune out
they use all of that to decide what kind
of stories they're gonna green light the
great stuff is the unexpected stuff you
you can use an algorithm to make taxi
driver
they're never going to ask you to do
Taxi Driver they're never going to ask
you to do Raging Bull they're always
going to ask you to do a very middle of
the road
uh action film and that's a big problem
because then they go all right well now
we'll only use the biggest stars in the
world and we'll pay them 35 40 million
dollars to be in it which is fine for
those to exist but when you put all of
your energy into those types of movies
then you're not really looking to make
moonlights you're not looking to you
know break ground and so they don't
trust their own Innovation and
creativity they really only trust more
than ever a super famous worldwide star
to attract subscribers
so it's the worst version of bean
counting and it took a few years for it
to happen but now they have so much
information they're like yeah people
don't like this type of movie but if you
were to pitch a midnight cowboy
nothing about their metadata would say
you know this is what the world wants
yeah they really want this this movie
about these hustlers in New York like
they would never ever make it and that I
think is the tragedy of all of this
which is it's so money driven
and it wasn't in the beginning when the
streaming started some of the appeal was
we're taking crazy chances and a lot of
that is beginning to disappear yeah
that's gone and it's not even about how
good is the movie or how many people are
watching that particular piece of
content
what it's really about is is this
driving subscribers new subscribers to
come and as they penetrate you know
North America and what blah blah blah
and they're moving into all these other
parts of the world it becomes about
creating for those audiences to tap into
that subscriber base and it has nothing
to do with storytelling necessarily it's
detached in a certain way and then on
top of that you have an industry at
large that's become so conglomerized and
you know sort of uh superhero a fide
like how do you think about just that
Beyond like the streamer aspect of it
just the way that the movie theaters
operate in terms of the kind of movies
that people go to the movies to see how
that's changed and evolved over time and
how you fit in as a comedy producer
writer director I just think you need
all of it it's just what are the
proportions
we love action movies we love sci-fi we
love horror movies we love romantic
comedies and comedies but
if it used to be
25 comedies and it goes down to four
percent
we pay a price for that I mean if you
look at the the world right now because
there's not an enormous amount of
support from the studios for comedies
and a lot of the becoming Stars aren't
in the theaters anymore we almost don't
have the next generation of Comedy stars
and then it becomes hmm something that
you can't stop because we haven't
trained the audience to watch comedies
and we haven't introduced them to people
who become the next
Kristen wig or yeah Sandler and so you
know that funk happens and then people
are like do we even need it uh and and
that's the problem because if you notice
on all streamers everything leads to
like murder you know you know True Crime
True Crime kids being abused women being
abused and they get huge numbers for
that so you go wow there's a lot of that
on there right a lot of serial killer
docu style it's very like if it bleeds
it leads
becomes such an enormous part of it
because
I don't think that everyone is focused
enough on let's do something good that
we're all proud of like just because
people would watch a lot of that do we
have to make that much of it and I think
the stock market and the financial
forces say yes
yes you're not allowed to try to make
these other movies you're not allowed to
try you know to to make Boogie Nights
you you need to stay mainly on the
topics that our metadata says people
like and that's a natural
part of business but it's way worse than
it used to be it used to be you know
there was always the you know popcorn
movies and then challenging movies but
you know when streamers lose interest in
independent film they and they think
well we're not getting enough viewers
and it's not in the theaters it can
completely disappear uh that and that
part's really scary so what is the
antidote to that well like for me as a
fan of all the streamers and I work with
all the streamers I just think
the mistake that they're making is
they want everything to be flashy so
you'll get the streamer to see the show
right I want you to see this because it
looks wild but a lot of great stuff is
more muted and it's subtler and so you
lose all of that so for a TV show they
want a big loud show
they always say we want it to be sticky
that's what they'll say and then they
also think that the amount of people
watching it generally goes down year to
year and they don't really need more
than two or three seasons of it so the
audience doesn't have that relationship
and they also don't trust
the streamers because they think well I
don't want to fall in love with this
show because
I'm not going to get six seasons out of
it I'm not going to get that
relationship and so
what I think everyone should do is like
why don't you just make it so your
streamer has good stuff and it doesn't
have to be like everything conquers the
world there should be things on a
streamers that don't make economic sense
and I think in the old days someone like
Brandon tartikoff would go I believe in
cheers
I'm just not going to cancel it I
believe in Seinfeld
uh and that would happen shows sometimes
it took two three years to find Their
audience and those are the shows that
all the streamers want to re-air right
or all those shows right that were
believed in when they weren't doing
great
and I think you should watch like a
streamer and think
I bet you no one watches this show but
the head of the streamer loves it
that was what was great about
some things on network TV like you knew
like oh like even with movies I know
even from Studio heads are like I make
this movie so I'm allowed to make this
one I'll take the hit on this small one
because I'm really I'm proud of it and
we need more of that things that don't
make economic sense right and then we
would love our streamers more because it
would have a little more heartbeat to it
there's still a little bit of that
though isn't there with Prestige
directors they know the movies aren't
going to make a lot of money maybe
they'll even lose money but they want to
be in business with this person and
perhaps there's Oscars attached to it
and that kind of thing but it's almost
like you need a new streaming service
where the the the mission statement
isn't growth necessarily it's just like
let's just quality like a Criterion
Collection for just cool [__] that's new
you know yeah I mean
it feels like all these places just want
to be
not in the worst way but they just they
just want to be Walmart they just want
to have everything on it so you never go
to the other streamer yeah and as a
result they lose some personality and
everyone's spread too thin it's you know
everyone has to make too much you know
it takes people to
to help you with with these things and
so
you know how many people know how to
develop comedy how many people know how
to develop shows how do you learn how to
do it do you have enough time on one or
two shows say you're covering 30 shows
can you really learn how to do it versus
if you just had three shows or four
shows then you were responsible for as
an executive so there's all sorts of
reasons why things get get flattened out
and all the people involved there
everyone is you know they're all like
good people they're all smart and funny
and and interesting it's just the system
is so dominant and the people who
control uh the levers of it
I don't know if enough of the time
they're pushing for experimentation
because that's how you get The Sopranos
that's how right and you need the you
know every once in a while the squid
game comes along to remind everyone like
oh it's something really good that's
brand new and completely out of the box
beef gets people excited about yeah beef
beef is an amazing show yeah remarkable
but we just need more of that yeah right
like
like how did that even happen when I
watch I'm like how did this even happen
it's crazy [__] and White Lotus happened
because there was a pandemic and they
needed a show and Mike said I have an
idea and they let him do it at a time
when no one else really could get into
production it wasn't meant to be more
than a season yeah and so they they
trusted the stone of HBO yeah and so
yeah it's those weird flukes so you have
to create an environment for flukes
you have to let creative people really
take big risks to have that reward and
so that's the danger of of a system that
really rewards the what they perceive as
successful because things can get a lot
of viewers but this is my new thought
you can have things that a lot of people
watch but it also doesn't mean they
liked it you know they talk a lot about
completion rate
oh well they completed it I completed a
lot of [__] I don't like yeah you know
are you a guy who's just gonna see it
through no matter what or do you pull
the rip cord like on episode two of
something that's not I I tend to only
pull the ripcord because my wife has
advanced ahead of me and then you know
I'll come home and we're on episode two
and she's like I watch five today and
I'm like the little white line at the
bottom and then I can't find the time
alone so you watch the the rest of the
series but I do think that's a big you
know a big part of it which is
pride in the work Above All Above the
numbers uh
that that's what people can feel you can
feel someone at this place wherever it
is some they love this you could feel
the love
of it and the passion for it it's not
just a placeholder it's not filling a
need
you mentioned beef is there anything
else that you've seen recently uh that
you thought this is really excellent and
new and fresh
what else have I been watching I mean
I'm mainly a documentary fan I I do
documentaries but I I just everything in
the world of documentary uh I tend to
watch you know Series wise
um what do we watch watch Daisy in the
six was right oh yeah I enjoyed that a
lot yet
um Barry in succession are pretty
remarkable
and it's sad that they're gone that's
two giant holes in television my
daughters on the TV show Euphoria which
yeah I think is really special I mean
that is just a a juggernaut and uh such
a iconic uh kind of
um cultural uh Memento for that
generation you know obviously my I have
kids as well and they love it I love
watching Euphoria with them as a lot to
talk about it can be yes I know you've
been asked about that like what's that
like to have your daughter on that show
I mean it's it's intense but it's real
and
um I think it's cool to watch that show
with teenagers and it opens up you're
meeting them where they where they live
and where they are and I've just found
that like the communication that you can
have after that is
you know really a unique thing I think
it's it's an amazing show and I love
what Sam Levinson did with it over the
two seasons
Because by the end of the second season
you realize what his whole point was he
really stuck the landing on the idea of
those two seasons I think I I meet way
too many adults with kids who say I
can't do it you know they'll watch one
and and maybe the first one was too
scary for most people because I think
there's a fair amount of people who
didn't get to the second one and they
really are missing out on something I
mean it is a lot it is a lot I'm
empathetic to that impulse if you had
a film camera
shooting me sexually in high school
you'd be disgusted by that too
it wouldn't look like Euphoria though it
wouldn't look like you were so like
anytime you show that explicitly you
know especially as a parent that's rough
but you do have to get over that and I
think in terms of all the issues about
addiction
there's important messages in there I
think some parents are like well does
this make them want to do it and I'm
like I didn't know they're all in hell
it doesn't seem like that's the fun
party
for kids who watch the whole thing
there's a huge price to be paid for all
of it and I think that he finds the
Cinematic language
to connect with kids and then to get a
lot of very important ideas through I I
agree 100
um
I think it's really potent and powerful
and and you know to cast a you know just
to say put your blinders on and say I
don't want to look at that is to not
engage with on some level you know the
reality of of that time for young people
that is very I mean we live in an urban
place you know maybe we're exposed to
stuff that wouldn't exist if you lived
in some small town in the middle of the
country but you know I think a lot of
the themes that they explore I mean
there's a reason why that show is so big
it's because it is tapping that nerve of
Truth for that generation oh absolutely
and
you can't really look away from it when
you have kids yeah because they're
having a completely different experience
of reality than we had when we were
young it's just completely different and
just the fact that they like it makes it
worth watching to just get a sense of
how do you grow up with this much social
media this much
Judgment of you I mean when I was a kid
I don't think I even knew what I looked
like actually can you imagine like
having this thing in your pocket that
was reflecting back to you the good and
the bad of everybody that you know what
they're saying about you what they're
doing when you're not around what you've
been disincluded from it's that's the
thing I noticed with my kids the hard
part was they knew what everyone was
doing they knew when they weren't
invited I never knew I wasn't invited to
anything but I didn't know it
and that's but the psychic pain of that
and also to just feel like you need to
be attractive all the time I mean if I
had to put up a picture every day during
High School of what I looked like and
tried to make it look good or to make it
look like I'm having fun or to try to be
funny and then I'm gonna judge based on
how people responded if people like me I
mean I have issue with that now I'll
laugh uh with Leslie because I could go
through the photos on my Instagram and
I'm fascinated by what people heart and
don't heart and usually the things that
are kind of just me I don't get almost
any if I put up a picture like me and my
wife I got like 180 000 Hearts I'm like
you don't really like you and not me uh
but but that's a that's a a lot of
pressure for kids and how they navigate
all the things that we hear about
it is uh so important and how do we know
like if you like if you can't watch that
how do you even know what your kid is
experiencing yeah not that it's exactly
that right and we're running this
unprecedented experiment on everyone and
we're doing it to young people while
they're their brains are you know barely
formed and what does that mean and how
is that going to play out over time I
mean how many times I've had to say to
my kids
it doesn't matter what people say about
you like someone said you shouldn't care
about anyone
's opinion who you wouldn't ask for
their opinion
right which is true and you know coming
from dad like that's not connecting you
know I'll say it every day they don't
you know like and it you know it's
they're now they have these careers and
they're in the you know in the public
eye and you know they've been part of
all many of your projects over the years
as young people
um
did they look to you and Leslie for if
like how do you help guide them through
that process having had some experience
or did they
just say you know are you like you know
out to pasture I guess is what I'm
asking no no it was apparent like when
you have a 19 year like they're you know
they can hear exactly what you would say
from some other person that they trust
but they can't necessarily hear from you
as the parent I mean they drift in and
out of interest in our opinions yeah but
uh we do have an ongoing conversation
about it and I think
it's similar to I was listening to your
previous
podcast and you were talking about the
show and why you do the show and how you
feel about advertisers and just staying
in touch with the original reason why
you're doing the show your your vision
for it not getting off track
and that's what I talk to my kids about
all the time you know why are you in the
business you're you should have
something that you want to say you
should have a reason and a passion for
creativity and that's what matters most
way down the line is how do people feel
about you it's really important to have
mentors who don't care about the
audience it's not your main thought but
I always read interviews with John
cassavetes because he's always like I
don't care if it bugs them I know he's
like all I care about is if in 10 years
you're still thinking about it a little
bit yeah he's like I don't even need
every scene to work maybe a couple of
scenes work for you like you need those
avant-garde people who have a little
disdain for the audience you need that
voice in your head in addition to your
voice that wants to connect with
everybody because
that's part of being a creative person
or an artist is I don't need everyone to
like it I mean if you look at the top 10
movies of the year how many do you like
maybe zero yeah maybe two people in the
world yeah we're not supposed to like
the same stuff but that's goes back to
the whole streamer thing like they're
trying to create for everybody all the
time everywhere and that's death
yeah I mean
I like certain movies they're you know
like they're people who love Marvel and
then there's some people will never
watch any of it and they're both
they're they're both legitimate point of
views about that but say you're a Marvel
person and you're just like destroyed by
the people who aren't interested in
superheroes I mean that's what we're all
doing in our own way which is yeah I
have a certain genre of what I make and
every once while I'll read from someone
who just like doesn't like my stuff you
know I'll go online and go oh uh funny
people is up I wonder what people think
and you know it's usually about like 80
90 positive and then like 10 are like
did you see that out you go you're like
I'm gonna expose myself to that
occasionally because I'm just interested
how's it holding up and I won't go to
town with it but I'll just kind of buzz
through and and I'm always happy with
people who who were like oh I watch this
movie once a year and and they tell
stories about when they watched it or
when they first saw it and then there's
just a few people like it's so long and
boring oh my God this is your worst
movie can you go back to your other
stuff the ad hominem you know Judd's a
tool
and I always say to my kids yeah
look up Tom Hanks 10 to 20 of people be
like it's the worst like look at the
Dalai Lama someone's slamming the Dalai
Lama like there's 10 to 20 percent of
people who don't like every single thing
it doesn't matter what it is Tom Cruise
Garth Brooks Shania Twain you know you
know me Sandler like there's a
percentage of people and that's fine
it's supposed to be that but if you go
online and you're devastated by the
people who don't like you
uh then you're in big trouble because it
might shut you down yeah and if it re if
your self-esteem isn't strong enough to
understand
uh that you're not supposed to win
everybody you're just supposed to find
your crowd and when you deliver that to
Modern Iris
how does that land I mean do they do
they get that yeah I mean I mean you
know not Vermont to be in Euphoria I
mean she's you know it's it's you know
charting challenging territory and I'm
sure there's a lot of people who have a
lot of issues with that show and she's
at a young age to be on the receiving
end of any kind of criticism but it's
also so artistically celebrated
yeah it's it's a it's everything yeah
and so it does require
you know a constant conversation about
art you know why do people like this
painting versus that painting you're
part of a painting and also people love
to debate stuff so the main thing I
always say is it's a miracle to be on
something that everyone's talking about
yeah because no one watches most things
and the things they watch they kind of
forget about five minutes later so the
fact that that you're part of something
that such a giant conversation that will
be one of those things that people
remember forever that is uh you know a
really fantastic opportunity because
it's just it's hard especially now you
know there's 500 TV shows and maybe 10
yeah are the ones that get talked about
a ton yeah have you had that experience
where you're scrolling on your thing
trying to figure out uh I'm gonna watch
maybe I'll watch this you click on it
you're like I already watched it yes yes
yeah no I didn't remember watching it I
used to do a joke on stage about that
where I said I got three episodes in and
then I turned the Leslie I'm like I
think we've seen this usually three
episodes to realize what you've seen it
or the other thing is
you watch a series it takes a year and a
half to come back
and then you don't remember any of it
and you're like is Escobar a good guy or
a bad guy
yeah I've had that experience where it's
been yeah like a year and a half and I
can't remember anything that happened
and that mental calculus is well I'm
gonna have to go back and at least watch
two or three of the last ones just to
get ready and I'm like I'm not doing it
I gotta Google I gotta read the Wiki
page for the last season and try to
understand it I have a question for you
though so you uh do
Ultra marathons and
things like that that's the opposite of
what I do it because
I have all sorts of issues around that
like emotional issues around
being physical exercise jocks like so
much of what
my world always was was resenting the
jocks because I was so little I was the
youngest kid in the grade and then bad
at Sports and then you wouldn't be
allowed in so they'd throw you in right
field the ball would never come to you
and so you would never would have an
opportunity to prove that you deserve
the better position and that would just
happen for a decade yeah and so
I think that's what a lot of Freaks and
Geeks was about like these these kids
who weren't being accepted and they
resented so they've become what we
always said we're uh cocky nerds you
know you become kind of funny but like
you're scared of the athletes as a kid
in the jocks
but you're also condescending
to them yeah and and that for me has
been a big thing to get over as I've
gotten older and you have the exercise
to not die you know I never want to be
around anyone who exercised no I get it
yeah I get it you know it's interesting
I was I was listening to the podcast
that you did with brene brown a while
back and she said something like what do
people not know about you or something
like that and and you said that I'm an
athlete your friend tells you Judd
you're an athlete but yeah my friend
Brad Forrester who who was a great
writer from The Simpsons in the office
we take like 90 minute walks a bunch of
times a week and he's always like people
don't know
how fast you're walking today people
don't even know but I have to put so
much effort into uh staying consistent
with any type of
physical exercise
because there's some party that's so
resents I have to have to do it and
before the pandemic I said I signed up
to this really expensive gym hmm I'm
like
this is really expensive but I'm gonna
do it because then I have to go
and then for about a year or two I did
go and it worked and then I said how can
I not hate this there must be a way to
not hate doing this because I not only
hate this I hate everyone in here I hate
every person who tells me what to do and
I'm like so my goal is could I ever want
to come here and I read a book you
probably know what the book is
it was a book written by Kobe Bryant's
trainer hmm I don't think I've read the
it was all about how Kobe looked at his
workouts in just what his
mental approach was and so in my head I
was the Mamba mentality thing yeah and
in my head I just thought okay
when I'm here I'm going to pretend I'm
Kobe
what would he say so if I want to get
off the treadmill in three minutes he'd
be like I'm gonna stay on here as long
as I need to I love it or or just like I
want to go farther or faster than I did
last I mean I would in my head pretend
and strangely it started working where
after like two years I had a little
feeling of like I want to go to the gym
and I'm not mad at everybody here and
then the pandemic hits and then it all
fell asleep yeah yeah well uh there's a
lot in there I mean the first thing I
would say to your first question The
Freaks and Geeks aspect of it
um
you know I relate to that sentiment or
that kind of archetype deeply because I
was bullied in junior high in high
school I was not an athlete I can't do
anything with eye hand coordination or a
ball uh and I was very much an outcast
throughout High School I grew up in
Suburban Maryland and uh and found
swimming
and swimming was like
an oasis away from the terrible
experience of being in high school and
and kind of like a womb-like like
underwater like I can't hear all of that
and I I'm safe you know I'm not going to
get beat up and it was the only sport
that I actually was any good at at all I
had some I wasn't like super talented
but I was okay but it was one thing that
I could do and it was also a way to you
know I wasn't the the funny kid I wasn't
the you know it was like the one thing
that I I found kind of a home at where
there were other kids who were kind of
like me and so I just doubled down on
that and you know I wasn't a good
student I didn't know how to make
friends I certainly didn't have a
girlfriend or anything like that but it
taught me discipline and it taught me
this equation between hard work and like
achievement or moving forward and I
realized like oh I'm not as good as
these other kids but if I if I actually
work harder or I do more like I can like
Bridge that Gap and I can be with them
like create some parity and that started
to spill into into my schoolwork and I
got better at school
and then I got quite good at swimming
and by the time I graduated high school
I was like getting recruited at colleges
and all that kind of stuff
um
but have always been that kind of
bookish sensitive
Outsider who felt like everybody else
had a rule book for life that I couldn't
connect with them like never the cool
kid yeah but then I go to Stanford and
the swimmers were the cool kids so this
was like you know
my version of you moving to LA and you
know like being in the comedian
Community
um and then alcohol [__] it all up and
all of that but to your point of of
you know being an outsider I've always
had that same relationship with bullies
and with like football basketball like
traditional Sports guys and that like
kind of archetype of what that
personality is
um and then rediscovering
Fitness and kind of moving my body later
in life was really
a function of an existential crisis that
I was having as much as anything else
like the same impulse that made you go
hike you know and then you realized what
that script was is kind of how it
started for me as well but I ended up
enjoying it so
that just was one foot in front of the
other of kind of you know putting the
Legos together and then realizing like I
actually like this and I'm actually good
at this and like where could I take this
let's see but it was really from a place
of like joy and and curiosity so when
you go to the gym and you're trying to
force yourself to like enjoy this thing
that you don't enjoy and you're trying
to run like some kind of Mind Trick like
I think that's backwards I think you
should find something that you that is
fun like you know shooting Hoops or or
pickleball or like whatever you know
even walking or whatever it is and then
building on that because that's how you
create a sustainable habit that you look
forward to and you're not having to try
to convince some days you're not going
to want to do it but fundamentally it's
like it's like this thing that you know
nourishes you and isn't something that
you're constantly dreading yeah yeah
it's a tough one I think part of it also
was uh it's connected to not wanting to
be in my own head so you know what I
hear about you you know running for a
great distance all I think of is like oh
but then you're just sitting with
yourself yeah but that's like there's
something about like if you can just get
your heart rate up a little bit like
more than it would be if you were
walking but not like out of breath that
quiets the mind and yeah it's
uncomfortable but it's just like
push-ups and then you know you can go a
little bit further and then you sort of
look for it in the it's sort of like
meditation like your mind's attacking
you yeah this is the most painful thing
ever all suffering is because we can't
sit alone by ourselves for [__] two
seconds
um but there's a piece that comes with
that and I think also as a way to
nourish your creativity you already know
the relationship between what that
experience can be in terms of how you do
your work so I think there's something
cool there for you to maybe explore
lately I keep thinking
I feel like I'm almost beginning to get
it just like I generally get it you know
like just lately I feel like oh I almost
understand
[Music]
not not completely but more but of kind
of all of it like you I almost feel like
a circle closing and then right when I
get it
my body will fall apart yeah
it is that thing but it is like it's
also that momentum thing like when
you're go when you're in the when you're
doing it it's easier to do it and then
something happens you have to go out of
town or whatever and then you're [__]
and like you never find your way back
like that's just that's human that's
just being human too you know I don't
know
um I have faith in you though
dude we're like how old are you I'm 56.
yeah so you know we can't [__] around
anymore no no you know that's the drag
when I realized like I needed to
exercise to stay healthy it was easier
to start exercising I hated the idea of
exercising to look good
I don't know why I was just like I
didn't like the like guys in the gym
trying to get ripped and and what about
the feel like oh I feel better
I I have gotten to that a little bit
like I don't love doing like the cold
plunge but I started do you have one at
your house no no but I started doing it
at the gym and then I was able to do it
for like five minutes and I did it a few
times and then I realized oh this
strangely put me in a good mood for like
four hours like ah really good mood I
mean on the Flow State thing like the
cold Plunge in terms of being an
antidepressant and just something to
kind of calm you down and clear the mind
like it's pretty effective but isn't it
terrible that like that's what you have
to do I know I know like that's how the
world works like you'll feel great just
freeze for five minutes yeah but it's
like is it any different than like isn't
it awful that I have to pull my hair out
to like get this idea on paper yes and
it takes years and it's like horrible
yeah you know it's rigged that way I
know I've been there's so many things
that aren't Pleasant that now I have no
choice but to do
that's I just came up with the
inspirational quote from the podcast
I mean it's a lot of morning routine and
yeah that was a big thing with writing
the script like
someone was saying you know it's okay to
do all of your exercise at the end of
the day you don't have to do it first
thing because sometimes you're just
wiped out from that like you know right
for four hours then go do it and even
learning that was like there's no part
of my brain that could have figured that
out because I'm just so dumb like wait
jog in the afternoon
like it would take me 30 years to do
that math it's harder to do that in the
afternoon but the tension is if I sit
down and write I'll have something
that's permanent and this is actually
what I do and you know the exercise
stuff that's not necessarily yeah
critical I can do that later but you
know if you do the exercise first you'll
actually feel better and maybe the
writing that you do afterwards will be a
little bit crisper yeah
but then then you gotta wake up early
now I gotta sleep well and get up early
I sleep well and get up early
pressure so many things anxiety disorder
about being well exactly right like in
the whole day all right and then but
don't eat to lunch okay so sleep great
get up early don't eat till lunch
there's so many things
I'm like weirdly uh kind of uplifted and
encouraged by uh the fact that you are
struggling with that equation but you
know why but I kind of get it a little
bit so I I I mean I don't think I till
the pandemic I don't think I took a walk
my whole life
where like I said oh I'm gonna just walk
for an hour and a half never would never
go on a hike wouldn't even think to do
it the treadmill but would never think
like oh maybe it's just fun to get
outside
it's like the world shutting down for me
to realize there was an outside you know
I've heard you tell stories though about
like walking around your neighborhood
and knocking on your neighbor's doors
unannounced I started doing that during
the pandemic I would just knock on
people's doors because everyone was just
stuck in the house especially the
scariest part of it yeah that does not
people's chores and they would like
sometimes they wouldn't even open the
gate they'd like talk to me through the
gates like people were really freaked
out and I'm like how you doing just
people I hadn't seen in a long time and
people wasn't even that close with but
someone I admire like how's it going
over the other side of that fence
yeah that's cool all right well we're
we're going off the rails here
um
thank you it was a pleasure and an honor
to talk to you I really appreciate it
man pleasure
um great you have well we're in the
writer strike it's not like you have a
movie coming out right now but like you
have this book sit you have sick in the
head and sicker in the head yes
um please watch the documentaries if
you've seen all of his big movies
already
um the George Carlin Doc and the Gary
Shandling doc doc and Daryl yeah ESPN 30
for 30. I haven't seen that oh that's
that's yeah you like that one all right
anything else you want to draw attention
to your wife on Instagram my wife uh get
the likes my wife we need we all need
our likes funny people on Netflix good
deal so let's pretend that's brand new
the bubble is also a net for the bubble
yeah I haven't seen the bubble usually I
have like six or eight weeks where these
things are scheduled and I can marinate
yeah you know but I this came about
pretty quick saw him yet it'll always be
there it's waiting for you okay thanks
Joe cheers perfect all right it was
worth the drive huh